today I've been given
what appears to be
dragging
this could be another short one I can
tell you that right now I only suffer
through so much of this you know what I
find funny how the school system will
teach us how to memorize pages and pages
of useless and indoctrinated information
things in life like I don't know
creativity imagination self-awareness
how to love other people communication
skills how to challenge ideas how to
grow our own food how to self-defend how
to build and overall just how to think
for ourselves or literally anything
about money debt or taxes or I don't
know just finding our passions and true
talents in life but no they teach us
what to think and not how to think just
a thought you know the unfortunate thing
about that is uh is the point that's
being made there is basically correct I
mean it's not true now but then we Ram
it into this whole drag queen thing
education doesn't have to work that way
but that is how the modern public school
education system works because it is a
factory conveyor belt system it's not
meant to be personalized what she's
talking about would be an education
that's
personalized that that recognizes the
students as actual individuals and that
each child has their own personality and
their own passions their own skills that
we want to Foster their own interests
that we want to encourage but you don't
get that public school system
you know where you can get that is in
homeschooling that's what that's what
homeschooling is all about pick it up
of course yeah
yeah we don't get creativity encouraged
in the public school system it's the
opposite of creativity
but I guess the implication of the video
is that drag is an example of creativity
which it isn't so one thing I always
notice when you see these clips of uh
the drag queens and usually again but
we're focusing on it if the clip goes
viral it's because the drag queen
dancing and their kids in the audience
and that's the most important that's the
thing that makes it the most
offensive
but I also can help but note that these
people they have no Talent oh no he
didn't like what what do you actually do
so you dress up as a woman
and then you kind of prance around on
stage and lip sync so you can't sing
you can't actually dance
what exactly is the appeal
okay oh yeah well those those are the
that's the uh the sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence those are the satanic mockery
of Catholic nuns that the LA Dodgers
have decided they're still going to
invite the LA Dodgers who I think of all
of the different PR crises that we've
seen uh they handled it probably worse
than any that we've that we've seen yet
you know it takes a special kind of
company to want to partner with my show
I say a lot of things that make a lot of
people angry as you probably noticed and
this tends to scare off advertisers
that's why I'm so grateful to Partners
like pure talk who stand behind me and
my show no matter the consequences they
might face puretalk shares my values
which is why we've made them the
official cell phone wireless partner of
the daily wire that's not the only
reason Pure Talk offers the most
Dependable 5G Network in the US I use it
myself you get unlimited talk text and
unlimited data with a mobile hotspot for
just 55 a month you vote how you spend
your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you instead go to puretalk.com Welsh to
get great coverage and save while you're
doing it when you go to puretalk.com
Walsh you'll save additional 50 off your
first month because they actually value
you that's puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans by Americans
[Music]
all right here we go
[Applause]
enough uh if you had any doubts about
what this is you know when when there
was the backlash against the LA Dodgers
and people claiming that these drag
queens are anti-catholic if you had any
doubts about that whatsoever well then
that should allay those doubts I mean
this is this that was their Easter
celebration they have a drag Jesus
coming out
um
now I will say that as a Catholic so I
we talked about this a few days ago in
the show I don't like to admit this kind
of thing normally that I take things
personally and I usually don't take
things personally I got pretty thick
skin I do take this kind of thing a
little bit personally because for one
thing I have a sister who is a sister
who is a nun and also as a Catholic you
know this is an attack on my faith it's
a mockery of my faith but at the same
time to use a leftist phrase it's in
some ways validating in a weird way it's
validating it's validating that on the
left they hate Catholicism in particular
I mean they hate Christianity they hate
conservatives they hate anything that is
good and true and normal and decent
obviously
but they hate Catholicism most of all
and that's all this is this the drag
queen sister Perpetual Indulgence it's
all it is all just their overwhelming
contempt for Catholics
and as a Catholic the fact that I am in
particular hated by these people it's
validating and affirming in a certain
way and you also see how these people
they can't create anything of their own
they have no ideas of their own you know
when they're trying to be shocking and
outrageous and all that it always ends
up being derivative it is outrageous and
it is disgusting so congratulations you
you've succeeded in being outrageous and
disgusting
um anyone can be discussing if they want
to be so you've succeeded in that but
it's not it's not interesting it's not
really shocking anymore because we've
seen so much of it it's repetitive all
they can do is uh take things that exist
and try to turn them on their head it's
everything that they do because they
don't have any ideas of Their Own
[Music]